lawmakers unveil 1.7 trillion dollar
bill to avoid shutdown boost Ukraine AP
News Congressional leaders unveiled a
government-wide of 1.7 trillion dollar
spending package Tuesday that includes
another large round of a to Rook Ukraine
nearly a 10 boost in defense spending
and roughly four it says 40 billion is
46 billion mostly to assist communities
across the country recovering from
drought hurricane and other natural
disasters I think we're over 120 billion
right now given to Ukraine the bill
which runs for 4 155 Pages includes 772
billion dollars for non-defense
discretion program in 855 858 for
defense the spending package includes 45
billion dollars in emergency cents to
the Ukraine it would be the biggest
American infusion of assisting yet to
Ukraine above even President Biden's 37
billion dollar emergency request and
ensured that funds flows to the war
effort for months to come legislation
also includes historic revisions to
Federal Election law that that aim any
future presidents candidates from trying
to overturn
by the way here's an interesting number
to give to you guys uh what a portion of
the number went to when I tell you this
I don't know how you're going to react
to it I thought I was a little bit
surprised by this number here's what it
was here's what it was
2.6 billion dollars went to U.S
attorneys for January 6 attack
prosecution how much 2.6 billion dollars
billion billion dollars Trump's net
worth on let me say that one more time
do you hear what I said billion or
Millions billion 2.6 bill by the way if
you're like let me not say this no I
believe so people are thinking like so
uh
2.6 billion just went to lawyers okay
let me give you this uh CNN article just
go to CNN article that says the 1.7
trillion just type in 1.7 trillion 1.7
trillion CNN go to the first article
that says here's what's in the woman so
keep going lower just everybody knows
what the story's coming from go lower
lower lower lower
right around there if you can zoom in a
little bit if you can zoom in a little
bit what do you see it or no 2.6 the
bill will provide 2.6 billion dollars
for U.S attorneys which would include
funding efforts to the further support
prosecutions related to The General 36
attack on the capital and domestic
2.6 billion dollars in legal fees Jesus
Christ
I mean am I the only one that reads this
and says what the okay so let's break it
do you know how many how many lawyers
you would have to give 2.6 million
dollars in fees for this let's do the
math okay what's 2.6 billion dollars
divided by say a thousand take say find
a thousand names that they're going to
do you prosecute they're going to be
giving a thousand lawyers 2.6 million
dollars thousand that's it a thousand
lawyers are gonna get 2.6 million
dollars what are we talking about and by
the way by the way this is prosecution
not defense defense is What expenses
prosecution you build an indictment you
put it on the table yeah by the way
another 11.3 billion goes to the FBI
okay the worst 39 billion goes to the
justice department so I mean they're
just and then they're doing a ban on
Tick Tock a couple things they had
didn't make it in there but Ukraine gets
another 40 some billion dollars what are
your thoughts on this Adam with this 1.7
trillion dollar bill
um well I haven't gotten to all the
details but I think we can all realize
that whatever the bill is whatever the
proposal is is not the law meaning like
they're gonna negotiate this so we you
know whether you went to civics class in
eighth grade the house proposes this the
Senate gets to vote on it they negotiate
this thing could be less than
a trillion at the end of the day here so
I mean I'm glad that we're highlighting
some of the nonsense because there's
going to be arguments there's going to
be filibusters there's going to be all
sorts of uh
points and counterpoints and we'll see
where it ends up I I there's you know
it's it does seem egregious however I
remember not too long ago when one
trillion dollars was a big deal now
we're talking multi-trillion dollar
spending bills and it's just the norm so
it doesn't get out of control here's my
question too how much after all that
said and done how much you think that
2.6 billion would go down because mind
you that's one question number two the
fact that they're trying to get that
much for these people is uh it's
ridiculous run for another 45 billion
dollars to Ukraine and then Rob what'd
you say Rob Rob actually read all four
thousand uh 155 Pages Rob would you say
about the salmon yes 65 million dollars
are going to go to uh restoring Pacific
salmon populations 3 million for what
they call Bee friendly highways and then
an additional 5 million in further
spending for salmon dude here's and and
and
sometimes it's not what's in a bill that
they're going to spend it on sometimes
it's what they prohibit and what is
prohibited that not one penny in this
1.7 billion dollar bill
1.7 trillion
not one penny can go toward border
defense that one I read that today it's
a clause in the bill one penny can be
it's in the bill that says none of this
appropriation may be directed to border
defense but that they are spending 410
million dollars towards uh border
security for other nations such as
Jordan Lebanon Egypt Tunisia uh Tanzania
Tunisia and Omen come on Malik
what so so here's a question
Republican Democrat and dependent
libertarian I don't give a [ __ ] about
politics whatever party you're a part of
what do you mean not a penny is going to
be going to the border and we're having
two million people record-breaking
exactly amount of people coming up here
fentanyl issues that we're having like
you know how do you process that will
you say zero dollar is going to be spent
on the board but we're spending it on
other people how do you process that
well I think what's happening right now
is so the new Congress comes in what
early January January 20th so basically
we all we all know we just have the
midterms a month and a half ago whatever
uh
this happens every two to four years
where before the new Congress comes in
they're going to try to get some [ __ ]
passed you know what's the term that
they talk about pork spending or pork
belly where you just kind of throw in a
bunch of nonsense into a bill and be
like let's get this let's get this as
sort of like a wish list you're you're
right and we'll see what happens what do
you feel about this to Pat's question I
already interrupt you I'm not supposed
to be interrupting you but you're doing
your job at that though but okay your
question
I got the World Cup of interruptions
what do you think about okay that's
that's what's happening but what do you
think about what's in that and that to
say nothing for border security yeah
well I think that's unfortunate I think
what's going on on the border right now
is a mess but I mean look you think
we're going to solve the border security
right now on this podcast it's been a
[ __ ] mess out of 20 years do you
realize like nice but hang on a second a
podcast is to Give opinions I agree it's
not to give like regular like uh just uh
questions being asked what do you think
I think that yes we should have some
money going towards border security But
ultimately what am I saying here yeah
this is a negotiation we're acting like
this is the end-all be-all this is
already trying to finish this up before
Christmas yeah but we'll see if that
happens I guarantee you when we're going
to look back at this in a couple weeks
or in a couple months it'd be like yeah
that [ __ ] turned out to be none of what
they that they that they proposed it's a
proposal
so in any negotiation you start here and
you end up here so we'll see what
happens here I and I'm saying this this
is my opinion Okay the reason that the
left wants all these open borders is
because say what you want all these
people are coming in are votes and I'm
not saying the illegals can vote but
their children their grandchildren
they're trying to destroy us and
tradition I don't care what anybody says
bro well you think that these people are
so pro-immigration illegals because they
love these people really think about
that but I know a bunch of liberal
Cycles in California I'm like you you're
so open up come on every everybody come
in what are you doing to help them
you're not letting them come into your
freaking house what oh remember Adam you
always say follow the money okay follow
why not one dollar for securing the
Border why are they so open why do they
love open borders those people's kids
grandkids all becomes votes and that
trust me when they come in and say hey
remember who let you in here the the
right the Republicans were like the hell
with you they're way Jesus you're rapist
but now remember Democrat always vote
Democrat and that's how these cats keep
you're right you're right period And by
the way they get to vote too you go in
the state of California and you can go
get an ID and with that ID you can then
vote and that's why they don't want
voter identification and they say oh
that's vote suppression yeah it is in a
way it is vote suppression because you
want illegals to vote so by your
definition on the other side their
definition it's vote suppression but
it's them voting too you're correct but
I add to that that they want the people
walking across not just their children
grandchildren they want them voting too
it's a voting Block it's a voting block
for socialist control and didn't they in
New York Pat do you remember I guess in
New York they passed the law where can
you look that up probably fast bro that
in New York illegals can can vote now I
don't know for Memorial candidate or or
for the presidency but New York voting
law uh non-citizen I think they allowed
non-citizens to vote what happened this
year what I will say is I don't
understand the whole you the the ID to
vote thing that should not be a big big
deal you got to have an ID to go get
liquor you got to get ID to go to the
airport you got to go to ID to go
anywhere but they're saying it's racist
to ask right
it was racist yeah I think that's uh I I
I'm happy that you agree with that but
it's like you have to always say why why
why why are they so anti they're helping
borders overseas but they don't give a
[ __ ] about us here
120 140 billion dollars to Ukraine 400
million dollars to other people's border
not one penny to us 2.6 billion dollars
to lawyers for January 6. that's giving
a thousand lawyers 2.61 million dollars
it's a it's a it's a very weird
situation where again the average person
has to sit there and say
like do they think the voters are dumb
like the you know are these guys that
are sitting there negotiating are they
really pushing the envelope are they all
kissing each other's ass to help be
re-elected I don't know I I don't know
again another reason why the American
people don't trust these people as much
as they did before the American people
don't trust mainstream media and the
government as much as they did before
they can go back and negotiate and see
what happens
but just the fact that you're not even
putting the issue of the Border there
says a lot about you FYI this is why
2023 is going to be investigations
Galore all year long all year long it's
going to be investigations especially if
McCarthy takes over so with all the
craziness taking place I believe future
looks right if you believe future looks
bright get your latest Future looks
bright hat of valuetaining it says
future looks bright here future looks
bright here we got them in white we got
them in Black we got them in red are
black on black sold out these are about
to sell out if you haven't ordered one
yet we had a person in Michigan but one
then he bought three then when those
three people weren't in the office they
had to order 58 of them because people
wanted the future looks bright hat
especially during times like this
because ain't nobody's saying future
look spread toward your future looks
bright hat click over here and to watch
the entire podcast click here take care
everybody
foreign
[Music]